michl a exemplified some
the astringent Wilson wished he believed
possessed in greater measure
than was actually the case a generous
expansiveness the vast almost lyrical
poetic faculty vast imaginative faculty
the intuitive earthiness the constant
connection with actually lived lives
whether of an individual or of a mass of
people without all those things history
becomes a mere series of analytical
propositions at which point which is I
think the lesson for today when it
becomes a series of analytical
propositions it loses the common reader
and instead of being part of our
cultural mainstream trickles in ever
diminishing form into the self
evaporating pond of the pure Academy so
Wilson painted but it was Misha lay who
in effect handed him the brushes and
mutually corresponding to what Wilson
thought and I certainly when I read him
imagined historian was and did above all
writer as lightning conductor
transmitter of the past and housing a
sense rather than as a comparative
political scientist in other words
paying as much attention to the effect
of history on those who read it sear it
hear it and as simply someone who
actually makes available the documents
of the dead to sway us to enlarge our
time horizon to deepen our understanding
of what the human animal is how we
behave how we conduct ourselves if we're
going to do this Misha lay thought
Wilson thought I still think history
needs to look and sound less slight
newspaper editorials and more like
poetry or even a novel the condition of
history is persuasiveness is the union
of the intellect with the literary
imagination
thus Venetia lay who assumed that what
he was going to write must matter to the
political and moral world of the french
must help them recognize
user patient particularly Bonapartist
user patien and its second it its second
iteration under poland Napoleon the
third the purchase that history could
have on the public how it could shape
our own ways of living with each other
in a political community depended
crucially on the form of his writing
itself on the persuasiveness of the
imaginative reconstruction of lost
worlds and finally on that tricky
negotiation between the alien and the
familiar the alien as the irrecoverable
strangeness of the past on the one hand
and it's shocking closeness the sense in
which everybody who's gone before in
some way are lost to us and in some way
feel the same grief the same desire the
same rage the same joy that we do when
Wilson wrote of the pains that Mischa
Lee took to make this trick using a
trick of the highest level of creative
and moral quality moved me a lot and
sent me to me surely as the revolution
in France gathers momentum each lay
makes a decision to write shorter and
shorter paragraphs which eventually turn
into one sentence paragraphs and shorter
sentences inside those paragraphs and
remember the the tradition in the 19th
century and indeed as they imagined was
the case with Herodotus and Thucydides
was a verbal performance that actually
children were set around listen to
history being rent to them and it would
not be dull so that the here for example
I've got lots of well I'll give it to
very quite short sense of the way Mischa
lay works how many of you how many of
you are as okay with French with French
as you are with with English ok not ok
I'll translate you they're not all of
you ok but you need to listen to the
kind of staccato music a little bit
okay so here's mutually and I'll try
I'll read it now translate it into
English should really be translated a
Dutchman
I haven't had enough coffee for that um
here is here's that weird moment between
the end of the net the national assembly
is still living in but guarded it's
before the fall of the Bastille before
the big uprising in Paris and it's
sitting in Versailles and it doesn't
quite know whether it's safe you know
the that they are table Nacional which
has been the estates-general heels
here's how Misha lay you have to listen
to it almost like chamber music exactly
a very bad musical instrument my voice
Lassiter a CEO is a tongs visible amo
poppies were in the Peregrine less on
Blaine of a poby it hasn't obeyed Mela
wah
never yah have okay lo ha Ave a plane
aquel French Minister may internal
assembly accomplice Anya Amelia did hoop
may have experienced here mich leis
image is coming in lagonda bought at
last.fm a lesson blatantly par la Petite
a disc it a a weak low the situation was
odd visibly provisional the assembly had
not been obedient but the King had not
revoked anything had not retreated the
King had recalled Nickell the minister
his war had started a revolution but he
held the assembly as prisoner in the
middle of his troops he had avoided he
but he'd say to me he'd excluded the
public the general public in Versailles
from the sessions of the National
Assembly and here this wonderful image
that Mitchell a has classic mich lay the
great gate to the assembly stage shut
the assembly had to get into its
debating wall by the little drawer so
that it's debates were behind closed
doors reek low as his sense of course of
absolutely sealed sealed shut
here's another little again short a
lovely piece from just before again even
further on when Paris has better explode
before it's about to explode
devant wash well do da de la monastry
while explosive only per play in un in
health at home in at at home in Alta
tall CTD Observateur sette Antonio Samba
common soldiers each a ap nibbler plan
delusion that whom false alarm first
novel favela advance multitude sort Anza
de anza vapor over to explicate to Devon
a from the 23rd of June to the 12th of
July from the threats made by the king
to the explosion of the people there was
a weird hiatus a weird halt it was like
one observer said that the the lull
before the storm it was dark and somber
like an agitated dream heavy full of
trouble false alarm
false news rumours inventions of all
sorts one knew something and it's almost
impossible to translate this last lovely
kind of cadence on Savion ass a vapor
one knew something that you don't know
it one wanted everything explained one
had to guess everything to Devine a the
same care with which the web and this is
non with election a lot mutually with
the web of memory as span the illusion
of being there of the overflow between
past and present through an intense
acute attention to literary form to
rhythm rhythm and rhythm no graduate
student should be allowed to get
anywhere near a PhD unless he
understands the rhythm of historical
writing that this was the kind of
Asturian I wanted to be the only kind I
thought stood a chance of mattering and
I got long section here not gonna read
it but I I just won't say that you know
I grew up Rob very kindly and accurately
referred to how important my father as a
kind of reader out loud we not only read
all the parts of Shakespeare together
over many many years but he will cease
to read Dickens too
this out loud which was but my father
had this sense in which Jewish history
and British history had come together
during the war and in the person of
Churchill all I would say is that
Churchill really does sort of belong
whatever you think of Churchill as an
historian Churchill famously said not
altogether comically that I know I know
that history will be kind to me because
I shall write it myself and I did and
but it was actually when Chuck there was
a very specific moment that Churchill as
the writing historian is why I'm alive
actually mattered and that is the third
week of May in 1940 and there's a revolt
brewing in the war cabinets
Churchill has only pretty recently
become prime minister and as a rebellion
of the old chamberlain knights
particularly led by the very brilliant
Lord Halifax's Foreign Secretary and to
do a deal through Mussolini by which the
British Empire would be preserved by the
Axis powers on condition that Britain
made peace with Germany and permitted
the total domination of the continent
and Halifax thoughts not such bad deal
because no one that the troops were
stranded Dunkirk it looks as though
they'd all be quarter of a million of
them be annihilated Britain stood no
chance of surviving the war against this
monstrous war apparatus of hit love why
not take the deal Churchill of course
was absolutely never going to do this
and he the two of them Halifax and
Churchill went and had their own kind of
historical reveries Halifax fatally for
his own and luckily for all the rest of
us luck Halifax went off and walked over
his estate in Yorkshire and he rode
Robin walk he browses the station
Yorkshire and he said I could not
imagine the jackboot striding and
violating the landscape I loved in other
words in every prominent with a jackboot
in Holland or anywhere else
probably in Yorkshire Churchill of
course went back to Chartwell and
he thought about his own writing of the
english-speaking peoples he thought in
not entirely sentimental terms about
Magna Carta about the Protestant
Reformation the civil war the tradition
call it Whiggish honor the tradition by
which Liberty had been had protect been
protected against absolutism and
autocracy and he did a brilliant thing
he summoned not just the inner core the
war cabinet which Halifax influenced
John Luke hatch by the way it's called
five days in May is absolutely brilliant
short thrilling book very much at the
Miche lay kind records this and we have
Hugh Dalton's record of this as well
because the cabinet minutes are didn't
entirely record it he brings the entire
war cabinet and he makes a speech rather
like the famous speeches who have made
Britain but this is just at the cabin
and he's said to have said that he would
rather lie upon the ground choking in
his own blood then do the kind of mate
the kind of fatal compromise that was
being suggested by the likes of Halifax
and at that point Hugh Doulton tells us
the whole war cabinet really funded
their fists in determined approval on I
mean that is the point where moment
where historian does change history is
both the writer of history and the an
actor of history and the next day he
sends Halifax off to be ambassador in
Washington and you know it's a huge
throw the dice it's an immense throw the
dice but it meant that you know my own
Jewish community were not going to end
up in smoke then the one the one figure
who some of you may know some of you may
not again a rather long quotation but I
hope you'll enjoy it was an
extraordinary who was really a kind of
out writer in this group he certainly
wasn't particularly left-wing I'm not
sure he was any kind of wing um but it
was a politically charged methodological
methodological anarchism a professor
called Richard Cobb at Oxford who
certainly if not the greatest is the
most was the most unorthodox historian I
ever had the good luck to encounter I
a young historian at whose seminars
because there were no seminars on French
history at Cambridge University to drive
through the sprout fields of
Bedfordshire to sit at Cobbs peculiar in
his in his peculiar presence Cobb had
gone through the penal servitude of the
French doctor huh d'etat and with a very
stony Marxist short affair for at the
end of it he produced a book called
Lezama publishing on air the
revolutionary armies which were not in
fact soldiers they were the armies of
the Sankhya lot who were enforcing
prices and political orthodoxy out in
France once Cobb got out from under that
ox yoke of ferocious ideology and
relentless documentary extraction he was
often running and the figures towards
whom he was sprinting were all dancing
on the wilder shores of French writing
Raymond Cano above all others but the
demonic sea lean to me che was a kind of
monster to call but he understood that
he was almost as strange as he as Cobb
was himself
anybody who spat scorn any eye of
lapidary history so Cobb wrote about the
underclass as EP Thompson dear but not
as heroes but as petty crooks cape
graces people are took an opportunistic
ride on a revolutionary rollercoaster to
get even with their enemies he wrote
about monsters or cruelty geniuses of
evasion pregnant girls throwing
themselves into the sand leaving their
infants in a basket with a note asking
for baptism the dysfunctional the
unclassifiable for soiled the stained
the hopeless and Cobb did this were the
freedom of literary expression that was
just breathtaking everything he did he
was monsieur le Duc achieve but it was
translated into a kind of poetic
intensity that burned itself into the
imagination it made Cobb totally
impervious in fact wildly hostile to any
grand discussions of probably of this
kind of historical thought or to any
theoretical framework for
in the past but it made him a kind of
brilliant ventriloquist for the dead a
Resurrectionist so forgive me for this
slightly long reading but I this this
occurs and this is the last of my
exemplary readings it occurs at the end
of a book which is a tough book to read
I wouldn't I wouldn't force it on you
called the police and the people which
is really about the attempt to provide
food during the worst years of the
revolution for the mass of people but at
the cost of political surrender to
whoever was in power particularly the
Revolutionary Government of the jacoba
and at the end of it all I had when
Richard wrote this late at night I
suspect in one of his increasingly more
infrequent sober moments and it just is
the kind of writing we all do it where
we don't need to look at our books or a
footnotes or anything we've internalized
everything we've been reading both in
the archive and in secondary sources and
you just let mutually did this all the
time you let the past out so here is how
he ends his book on on the police the
food and revolution it's that it's the
very last page it's about hunger I'll
take it slowly because it is in itself
an extraordinary piece of writing in my
view hunger employs its own outriders
those who have already experienced it
experienced it can see it announced not
only in the sky but in the fields
scrutinized each year with increasing
anxiety week by week during hot summer
months by 30 million anxious eyes
questions whether it be a good harvest
or not course in the figures for grain
prices on the markets these are the
clues these are all clues there's always
an element of detection in good
historical writing we are crime writers
of the past often going with Richard now
so you're looking for the clues about
how bad things again
at any amount of movement on the rivers
and roads in the traffic of the barrier
they the little area on the on the
periphery of Paris before you pay your
customs duty to get in in the
conversation of visiting countrymen in
the letters of country relatives or in
the discreet decrees of government in
the unspectacular efforts of
municipalities to extend the limits of
their cemeteries in the number of times
two men carrying a covered object emerge
from a hospital by night in unusually
massive orders of quicklime in the
dispatch of a commissioner to Genoa
Geneva Hamburg bound Tunis Copenhagen
buying expeditions a grain in the
prayers of the pious in a secret sermons
of barn priests in the cards of d'azyr's
de Bona bounty or fortune tellers for
whom famine was a better customer than
marriage violent death
war success in money or in love in the
anxious faces of women or the pallor of
those who have already eaten dared war
horses in a sword worn by an imprudent
mare in the shadow thrown at a certain
hour of day seen from a certain angle of
a certain statue in a certain town it
hunger is something that comes with
stealth without fanfare yet preceded by
a thousand imperceptible signs that the
18th century marginal man could pick out
just as those who were in the know the
mayor the borough engineer and the
members of the rat killer Department
knew that Gaston with his broad brown
and black back the size of a large ish
Mastiff was just one of a race of
invaders a new race of giant rat
already in possession of the city
waiting only for the single signal to
come up from the sewers and take over
that's the way historians are supposed
to write it's not easy
if young our young graduate students are
not aiming to write that that they need
to find a different job in my view Cobb
clearly did not give a hoot for any
pretense of narrative self-effacement in
this he was a figure of the 19th century
almost he thought the objective voice
either apathetic the sense in which you
you bring history to life from nowhere
that as a kind of point of view that is
nowhere that is disembodied you are just
a kind of transparent recorder of
documents the re presenter of documents
he didn't believe thought that was
either self delusion or professional
fraud there was a still small voice that
begged to differ from this basis on
which the historical profession was
built particularly they the
phenomenological philosopher RG
Collingwood again I was going to talk a
lot about Collingwood I'm not going to
do this but Collingwood Collingwood made
in his remarkable book I think the idea
of history which again had a big
influence on me I'm Colleen wood who was
not a moral relativist who did not take
the view that there is no fundamental
historical truth it was just that we had
always to take account of how we reached
it and how we reconstructed it and we
should be unembarrassed about what the
work of reconstruction was essentially
Collingwood made a crucial distinction
between the empirical side of our brain
which goes hunting and gathering with
honesty and expansiveness for the
evidence and then the imaginative
literature side of our brain which
builds it into something different he
described it as yeah he says something
beautiful
he's very adamant about the historical
imagination and he quotes McAuley
Macauley in a fine Macauley truism said
this is Macaulay now a perfect historian
must possess an imagination sufficiently
powerful to make his narrative affecting
and picturesque and Collinwood said well
that's fine but he said McCall is Comet
is to underestimate the part played by
the historical imagination which is
properly not ornamental but structural
the historians picture of his subject
well that subject be a sequence of
events or a past state of things this is
all Collinwood thus appears as a web of
imaginative construction stretch between
certain fixed points provided by the
statements of authorities almost like a
beautiful gossamer tent and the you have
to stretch the web of your imagination
between fixed points are verifiable
rock-solid evidence but the way it is
the way the roof is the roof if those
points are frequent and the threads are
spun from one to the next are
constructed with due care and never
merely by arbitrary fancy the whole
picture is constantly verified by appeal
to data to evidence and runs this is all
Collinwood runs very little risk of
losing touch with the reality it
represents so that is for me the job
description of the working historian and
now the end of my lecture the dismal
part of what nietzsche called the gay
science what in hell has happened what
has happened to those legions of writers
to the unapologetic public historians of
the servants of clear well you can find
the qualities of the job description but
for the most part in the pages of
historical fiction which in terms of the
audience reading history or in the pages
of Hilary mantel or Peter Carey or Rose
Tremaine or column Tobin just the
English David Mitchell you can even find
this care to think about the
relationship between evidence and
imagination and
some films in 12 years a slave even I
think in Spielberg's wonderful film so
it seemed me Lincoln just concentrating
on that one moment the Emancipation
edict but those are all of course in the
last resort fictions even though Hillary
ran tellers claim some sort of non
literal truth unavailable to historians
I don't agree with Hillary motel either
it's the truth or it's not the truth the
issue is where the truth historians who
embody all equalities I've been
characterizing are to be found they are
there they are there might one thinks of
Christopher Clark's wonderful book on
the beginnings of the First World War
the sleepwalkers there there are there
are plenty plenty of them there but they
they are not as robbed in his nutrient
mode said altogether massively
populating the grooves of a khadeem
there the obligation to uphold the
paradigm of anti writing of counter
writing of an inhabited a purely
academic language world that's made
entirely for scholars prevails to the
point that if our young graduate
students wanted to write like Mattingly
for example or Cobb they would have no
clue about where to start and often in
the way in which Nietzsche had a very
short chorus professor this everything
works against a graduate student
liberating her or himself from the kind
of writing which will get you a job
Pierre Bordeaux is right academia is
overwhelmed by the need for collective
self reproduction professors recruit
graduate students who then become his or
her team a trained as much as possible
to resemble their mentor with occasional
allowances for argument and variation
sometimes the oedipal gesture of
wounding the doctor varta so as to make
a splash with a thin squirt of academic
blood tolerated prophesied under
structural strictly controlled
conditions the other rituals of the
reproductive process the academic paper
with its mandatory positioning against
whatever is defined
as the reigning orthodoxy the
differentiation right somewhat akin to
antler display among aspiring stags the
conference paper at which daring is
advertised to the gather profession the
nicely calculated job talk fresh but not
combative you will know it and it goes
on and on the crown PhD becomes junior
faculty member goes through the motions
Don's the mask of respectability becomes
intern the armory the arbitrator and
operator are the same routine thus
another terrible word really mention the
integrity of the field
let us now hints worth call it the
fences that the containing paddock are
duly protected and shored up in the
meantime within the academy not many
people care about the challenge was
strong vivid imaginative forceful
writing the occasional gesture is made
when an otherwise dutiful writer opens
their account with a story but usually
it's abandoned for the pie chart the bar
graph the positioning of your particular
point it doesn't arise organically from
the body of the narration and there are
at and there are plenty of examples of
the country I have to say but they're
not enough and they're only by
established professors gave Achilles
tones great epic of British life in the
1950s another great example of how it
should be done but mostly it's all
content and no form and the academic the
academy circles the wagons the public
however of you go begging and and and
the public does beg every time I do a
signing at a literary festival or on on
book tours parents come along with their
children and ask why there isn't more of
their children to get stuck into or very
kindly and I sorry sounds horribly
self-serving I get thanks much more than
I deserve for doing this kind of thing
at television there are lots of
opportunities now in Britain
particularly for young school children
to engage and for historians to engage
with this avid extra academic audience
as a terrific history
festival that taught Valley in England
and if you have one here but I'd love to
hear that in the Netherlands perhaps
some of you be kind enough to tell me
when I'm finishing which is very soon I
promise
that history in the Netherlands has not
become a sinkhole
that's not become something for which
people flee that it's not something
which if you take it seriously it's
likely to reduce your credentials for
employment this is actually a remark
made by the present Minister of
Education and the United Kingdom that it
you have to be stupid to actually study
the arts or the you know the liberal
disciplines including history if you
want to get a job so instead of actually
getting in the kind of history that I've
been reading to you and trying to
characterize kids of course were wired
for epic chronology get where do they
get it they get it from the person whom
whom Wilson despised from the Lord of
the Rings from Harry Potter from Game of
Thrones in the fantasy realm of myth
rather than in the equally thrilling
realm of truth and the failure of the
profession to think that any of this is
their business let history be Downton
Abbey let it be a stroll down memory
lane comes they believe at a cost to our
shared civic life wherever you look at
the fate of Nations in a globalizing
world the return of a kind of tribal
nationalism in the epoch of corporate
bureaucracies in the rise of
fundamentalist intolerance the collapse
the surrender really of the
Enlightenment project a pluralist
toleration in the blowback of post
colonialism in the heart of the European
urban world in the return of
anti-semitism something giving me
particular grief notwithstanding
Holocaust education in the fate of the
planet itself where there is great no
great historical environmental books
with beautiful writing in the hands of
people like Stephen pine for example in
issues of Epidemiology at the tragic
dynamics of revolution the social
distribution of the rewards and
penalties the capital
is marking all these things
understanding is conditioned by informed
action a proper consideration of the
dominant matter shaping our own world
and that of our children is impoverished
by what David Armitage in his recent
history manifesto has called short-term
anism I go further than that and say
that the free world and I don't sneer at
the characterization of the free world
is actually impaired and weakened by its
indifference to history seeing it as
harmless costume escapism or else on the
one hand Downton Abbey on the other hand
the impenetrable endless PhD
dissertation we are weakened because we
face the adversaries of our freedom are
those for whom history is manipulated in
the interests of imposed subservience
theocracies of the kind enthroned in
Iran in which law is made by revelation
are definitively a historical they brook
no dispute against the Word of God
tyrannies or despotisms of the kind
prevailing in Russia manipulate history
to narrow the definitions of Allegiance
pledge allegiance to our version of a
tional past or be deemed a traitor to it
that facilities is screaming in his tomb
when he contemplates what becomes of
history and those circumstances there
are curriculum committees in the United
States that have been caught deleting
subjects deemed critical of what they
define as patriotic American
authenticity substituting instead
feel-good histories with the wrinkles
smoothed out and the warts removed and
it was against that that the honor of
European history was first flown from
the master lucidity ziz masterpiece the
whole honor of history our moral
self-respect is to be a gadfly an
irritant to the complacent a criminal
knew
sense to the official version it's what
Michelet was it's what Richard Cobb was
to do to make to do something about this
we can't just write extended newspaper
columns or editorials or even much as
I've loved doing so and have inflicted
this on you we can't even just write
give lectures for the Nexus Institute or
there we can support the flourishing of
the Nexus Institute we need to go on the
offensive against oblivion and our
proper weapon of attack is that
brilliantly told story the web of
construction over the fixed coasts of
evidence we need to tell stories out of
which emerge organically all the
questions that need to be asked about
which ever particular predicament we are
grappling with and lots of academics I'm
sure here probably taking terrible
offense we need to leave the campus
everybody we need to march out of the
gates of the monastery and into the
world with our Inconvenient stories so
here in the Nexus Institute I'm
proposing something a radical rethinking
so radical it verges based on the Maoist
of what should qualify a student for a
PhD in history yes the dissertation
based on primary research should be the
jewel this central treasure but along
with it no one should receive a doctoral
degree unless they spend a semester a
third or a half of the year teaching in
a high school I'll do it myself
I'll start absolutely fine I go into
schools a lot in America I've been happy
to do that and even in other captive
communities prisons young offenders for
example not every day of the week let's
not get carried away and there was
another job description which without
which you should not be able to get a
PhD the ability with software designers
to create a website or an app that can
bring these stories to a mobile device a
tablet to anyone anywhere working on a
tie Factory and a farm in Africa anyone
with different set of beliefs a
different kind of
job we've never had such powerful means
of honoring the Thucydides and vacation
of being an irritant and yet assumed
that it's someone else's job is not
someone else's job it's our it's the
scholars job it's working historians job
taking history out of the Academy to the
people however doesn't have to be a
purely digital exercise amazingly last
week I was at the vitamin Institute
kindly asked me there and in of Science
in Israel and the the head of the
vitamin Institute Daniels I thought oh
be of the amazing thing that's but
extraordinary venture that's been going
on for five years in which all of his
senior colleagues he's our Nobel Prize
winning scientists have been taking
their science into pubs into cafes and
pumps about once a month and talking
about their work to a roomful of
half-drunk people essentially uh and he
said this brilliant everybody loves
doing it that was his view and why not
have a discussion in a pub about
colonialism about the First World War
about the history of race and Empire in
the Netherlands always remember my old
mentor Jack plumb who Rob kindly
mentioned said Yubel his students you
belong to an ancient craft that began by
shouting in the Agora
it's time to start shouting a bit again
I think otherwise my friends the atrophy
will be irreversible it will be our
children's children if not our children
will just not see the point the golden
chain of memory will be broken the
practice will be ever combined to a
tinier number of scholars doing nothing
but talking to each other in ever
diminishing numbers about less and less
while the world of the past will be left
to the movies the historical romances
who make free with the truth and no one
no one will expect historians to be
tellers of tales there are many many
horrors anybody since I began this is my
last paragraph anyone think of where a
great novel in which
the honor of the past is somehow
miraculously been preserved in the line
of an old song I could sing it for you
maybe that'll help oranges and lemons
say the bells of st. Clements yes lady
in there Brittany where does that come
from you know yes stand up 1984
exactly right it's all well it's all
well thank you you're my new girlfriend
well you don't have to be that happy
there are many horrors in or worse 1984
bright O'Brien's rats and all arrests
but the biggest horror is Big Brother's
erasure of the past a wholly successful
exercise in cultural lobotomy that dooms
mankind to live in a perpetual present
only that song whistle tune over her by
Winston Smith gives him a moment of
pause to grieve over the loss in those
circumstances not perhaps a futurist
fantasy history will indeed just be
history and we will have lost that
attribute of our humanity second only to
the power of language the incomparable
treasure of our shared memory here's all
well on Winston Smith when long after he
matters have gone bad everything faded
into mist the past was erased the
erasure was forgotten the lie had become
truth
you